Just a reminder to everyone that
alhamdulillah we will begin
on Wednesday night. This Wednesday night
coming we will make the first night of
and hence the first day of fasting will
be Thursday. So the first night of Tawi
will be this Wednesday
and the first day of fasting will be
this coming Thursday.
Another point to keep in mind is the way
that the program will be set up
will be at 8:00 every night throughout
the entirety of the month of Ramadan.
It's not going to change.
After
at 8, we will have a very very brief
3 to 5 minutes.
After that, we'll make the salah and
then begin
will be eight as usual for this
masid. as it was last year, I'm told.
And each night we will be completing
one
juz so one part of the Quran.
We will not go ahead of that and we will
not be completing the recitation of the
Quran
except on the last night of Ramadan. So
we will finish with the last night of
Ramadan. That will be the night of alim.
I know that last year perhaps it
was the 27th night we will make it so
that every single night when you come
the night number will be in accordance
with the part number of the Quran.
Another thing is that we will be reading
the entirety of the Quran in theaw.
So we're not going to split it between
and at the last 10 nights. If you attend
every
from the beginning to the end, you
you will have listened inshallah to the
entirety of the Quran. this doesn't
mean we won't have in the last 10
nights. We will. But the bulk of our
recitation will be during
those leading the will be myself
the acting assistant really assistant
imam and since I've been here for the
past five or six months and Dr.
inshallah who was with you last last
year as per usual. And so it will kind
of be split up mostly thirds. I might
have a little bit more than the rest of
them but roughly that amount and it will
be in that order each night as well.
Another thing is we're going to be
having here every night. think this
is not new to you guys. We had this last
year, right?
beforear
so just 10 minutes before
I'll be here to give a few words
each night with respect to some
rulings and fasting rulings in zak
when we get close to the end etiquette
and so forth. I know that the this group
of folks here that are here now, you
guys are the ones that come often I
don't think we'll have any issues, but
you know, sometimes if people are
hungry,
people are angry. They're what? Hangry.
People come in, they're hangry. Okay.
And they're
being driven by their biology, an empty
stomach at that point. And so there
might be a little bit of rough around
the edges the first couple days. Let's
just try to all be civil and very
very easygoing with one another
inshallah. Let's try to be patient with
each other. We also have lots of
volunteers this year perhaps more than
previous years. A lot of the youth are
signing up to volunteer. There is a
signup sheet specifically for the youth.
So, this is 25 years and younger,
okay? If you want to volunteer, you
don't have to volunteer every night of
Ramadan. , it's a sign up on Google,
the sign up. I think they call it signup
genie or what have you. , I will, ,
send it back out in the WhatsApp a
couple more times to remind everyone
before starts. You can sign up at any
time. , but when you do sign up, ,
we're expecting that you would come in
before MEG and stay with us until after
Tawi is completed and everything is
cleaned up and ready for the next day.
So, if you sign up for volunteering,
expect to be here for about 4 hours.
That's about what you're going to be
volunteering that evening. You can
choose to volunteer one night or two
nights or 10 nights or every night. It's
up to you if you have some extra time.
You know, it's a it's a it's very easy
for us actually in America to give
money. That's the easiest thing,
right? And that's the American way. Any
problem, just throw money at it. It'll
fix itself. But really,
giving your time is a lot more
difficult. And if you really want to do
something meaningful, come and
volunteer. Help us out during Ramadan.
[Arabic recitation]
there will be great reward in that for
you. also after we will have the as
per usual after we mentioned that on the
weekends, Saturday, Sunday we have the
Quran all through the year. We will be
continuing that throughout Ramadan. It
is 45 minutes after fud after the
there in the back with myself. We
have a group of brothers. We reflect on
the Quran. We recite the Quran. We learn
certain things. So anyone is free
to join us inshallah for that. And then
keep your eyes peeled for other programs
that may be going on. But that's a quick
rundown of the program and
inshallah that will be put in print
and distributed on the WhatsApp and
elsewhere in the coming days. But this
is just kind of a breakdown for now
inshallah. So you know Ramadan Mubarak.
I hope everyone here makes it to
Ramadan. I hope I make it to Ramadan.
Right? We don't know what tomorrow holds
for us, but you know, I'm very
excited to be with you here for this
Ramadan. you know, I've I've led
Tarawa for about 20 years, and honestly,
I'm very excited, particularly excited
to be here in this Tucson community this
year. So, thank you for having me. I
wanted to just express that as well.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the ninth verse of the 68th chapter of
the Quran.
We've been speaking about this verse for
three nights and that is because of how
important this verse is in order to try
to make it clear and make a clear
distinction between mud and mud. Alana
is compromise.
Compromising
on behalf of one's religion.
compromising on behalf
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
compromising an aspect
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
and this only happens from hypocrisy
this is not something that Allah has
ever permitted any of his prophets or
messengers we either speak the truth or
remain silent what has our prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam taught us he
says
Fore
[Silence]
he saysam
if any of you witnesses an evil taking
place then if you're able and you have
the authority change it physically.
And if you are unable to physically
change it, then change it verbally by
speaking out against it. And if you are
unable to verbally change it, then in
your heart you must hate it at least.
And that is the lowest rung of emen.
Meaning that's expected from everyone
that we at least hate evil in our
hearts. There is no situation
where we use falsehood to compromise
where we cut corners dilute our message
ofahillahillahillah
doesn't belong to me. It doesn't belong
to you. It doesn't belong to the
prophets and messengers.
This belongs to Allah.
We don't have the authority to play
around and plate people withahill
and so
is compromising.
However, this is often
conflated often confused with al-mud.
What is al- mud? Al- mud is diplomacy.
Right? Yesterday we gave two examples of
mud,
two examples of compromise that is
haram.
We gave one example of Abu Talib how he
compromised accepting Islam to plate his
people even though he believed it was
the truth in his heart and that landed
him in the hellfire for eternity.
We have another example of the mud
offered to the prophet sallall.aii
by the mushri of Quraysh. We will
worship your god if you worship our
gods. We will leave your religion alone
if you don't speak out against the
falsehoods of our religion etc. These
are two examples of compromise which are
haram.
Now tonight we want to discuss and bring
two examples from the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam with respect to
diplomacy. Diplomacy is different diplom
diplomacy doesn't have to do with
doesn't have to do with placating
someone
with compromise.
Al-Mud
is often hinged on
refraining
from
something
desirable
for the sake of diplomacy. And we'll
take a couple of examples, one personal
example and one general.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in the Quran,
we know this verse in right,
I swear
by the ever witnessed and attended
house of Allah. Does anyone know what El
Mur is?
I think you know. You don't know. It
looks you know
Ibraim. No.
Tell me
[Arabic recitation]
Okay, say it.
Okay.
Okay. So
means
two things. Number one, the Kaa itself.
Number two, the equivalent of the Kaa
that is in the heavens for the angels.
Right above the cabba that's on the
earth.
In the heavens
there is its equivalent in the heavens
that is called
and that is for the angels
the equivalent of thea is for us here on
this earth it's called
and what's interesting about
is the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam told us about it
he said that This bait, this house of
Allah in the heavens
is
a place where the angels go to make
circumambulation,
right? To as we do of the ka, but it's a
little different and that is that
is designed in the same way that thea
originally was designed in in the time
of Ibraimisam.
The Kaa we have today is not exactly how
Ibraim built it.
First of all, the Cabba originally was
not a cube. It was rectangular.
It was
we know where that that kind of crescent
is which is called
that actually is the true foundations of
the Kaa
and that is that Ibraimis
when he erected the Kaa that is where
the Kaa that's where its parameters were
however when the people of Quray just
before the prophet became a messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he was
in his mid30s roughly
they decided They were going to rebuild
the Ka, a story that most of us are
acquainted with. However, they agreed
that
and stolen money and money earned from
alcohol and gambling was impure.
And so they did not want to rebuild the
Ka using any funds that came from that
direction.
I'm not speaking about Muslim. I'm
speaking about the idoltors of Mecca.
They said that this money that comes
from gambling or alcohol or
prostitution or ribba or usery or from
bandits. It is impure and it's and it is
not befitting for the house of Allah. So
anyone who wishes to contribute to the
rebuilding of the Ka must contribute
from money that is pure as they framed
it. Well, it just so happens that the
majority of the people of Mecca, their
tar, their commerce is in what? Gambling
and alcohol and banditry and all these
things. So a lot of it was from yuzerie
and ribba. So they didn't have enough
money that was pure to rebuild the ka in
its original fashion.
So they built it as a cube that we have
today. And then they marked out what is
referred to today as
they mark this out to keep always
preserve the original foundations of
Ibraim.
Now that's one of the design features of
Bet Mur. That's one. There's another
thing about it and that is that the
original Kaa that Ibraim built.
It had two doors.
One to enter
and one to exit.
And when a person
wed to make, they didn't used to make
around it this. They used to walk
through it.
That is how the taw is originally made
in the time of Ibraim in the time of
Adam.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam says
that in the heavens
it has one door by which to enter and
one by which through which a person
exits.
And every day 70,000
angels pass through those doors
and get back in line to pass through
again, but will never get a second
chance until the day of judgment. That
is how many angels are in the heavens.
[Silence]
those are the original foundations and
the original
the original blueprint for the
Kaa. But the people of Purish, they
didn't have enough pure money to build
it that way. So they gave it one door
and they marked out and because we can't
pass through it, we have to do what? We
have to make around it. And that's why
we make today in the way that we do.
Well, this was during the time of the
mushri. Fast forward to the
conquest of Mecca.
What year was the conquest of Mecca? Fat
Mecca. Huh?
No. After after Hijra, 13 after Hijra.
No, that'd be Abu Bakr's reign and Abu
Bakr's. Tell me. Eight after Hijra.
It is a difference of opinion amongst
the historians. Some say seven, some say
eight. Eight is the better opinion. But
what month was it in?
What month was fat?
Come on. It's on everyone's mind.
Ramadan. Yes, this is agreed upon. Fatka
was in Ramadan. The difference amongst
the historians was was it the seventh
year after Hijra or the eth? Most likely
it was the eth. The point is
fast forward from when the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was roughly 35
years old when they rebuilt the Kaa 5
years before he was a prophet. Fast
forward to the conquest of Mecca,
the eighth year after Hijra,
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam is
roughly 60 or 61 years old.
And so he arrived to Mecca in the
ironclad
Calvary. It was referred to as
the iron calvary.
Why? Because it was impenetrable.
The Mushri were so terrified of the
Muslim. As a matter of fact, the Muslim
were so terrifying to their enemies by
Allah's will that some of them when they
would prepare for war with the
companions, they would chain themselves
to the ground.
Can you imagine?
They would come to the battlefield and
chain themselves to the ground. Why?
Why? So they don't run away. That's how
scared they were. And so the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam arrived in
Mecca and the idols were destroyed
and the adan was raised and
manat were demolished
not for the last time but for thousands
of years to come
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
restored tohed into the heart of Mecca.
Now
tells us something very interesting in
Muslim.
She said that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said to her
during this time
so he used to you know nickname
he said foreign.
[Silence]
So he said, "Had it not been that your
people," meaning Quraysh, the people of
Quraysh, are so new to Islam
and are so fresh out of Jahyah
and are so yet uneducated
and some of them have entered into Islam
dragging their feet and begrudgingly.
Had it not been that it would shock
their minds,
I would
immediately demolish the Kaa and rebuild
it on the original foundations of
Ibraim.
And I would make for it a door from
which to enter and a door from which to
exit. Meaning like
that is in the heavens.
What does this have to do with?
This is a very good example of mud
diplomacy
because
that is something that is very good.
That is something that is beloved to
Allah. that the Kaa be restored to the
way it was built by Ibraimisam.
However, what is stopping him from that?
The reaction that these new Muslims are
going to have. What kind of messenger is
this? He claims he's a messenger of
Allah and the first thing, the first
order of business as he tears the Kaba
down. What kind of prophet is that? This
is what they would think. And so he kept
the Kaa as it is
in spite of it having the potential to
be better
which that is but keeping people in
Islam is
and so this is what is called what
this is this is diplomacy
he didn't he didn't do mud he didn't
change the truth he didn't he didn't
compromise the truth rather he refrained
from doing that which is better
for the greater of the two goods
correct that's one example
a second example this one will be quick
[Arabic recitation]
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was sitting in his home in Medina
and a man came
to
see him
It was said that it was habis or Ib most
likely it was Hyb
was a very loudmouth character and he
was extremely ignorant and not only that
but he left Islam as soon as the prophet
died. Sallallahu alaihi wasallam joined
a false prophet fought with him until he
was literally taken in a cage by
W in a cage brought back to Abu Bakr and
then he said okay I'll become Muslim
again right that's that's the kind of
guy we're dealing with here so he came
to see the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and so you know they came and they said
you have someone at the door who is it
it's
he says
He said, "Let him come in. What a foul
man."
Right.
Gosh, what a I hate, you know, he didn't
say, "I hate this guy." He said, "What a
foul man, right? The foulest of people.
Let him in."
And so when he came in,
says that when he sat down, the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam smiled to
him. He listened to him and he didn't
say anything bad to him. Then the man
left. So Aisha was perplexed.
She said, "Oh messenger of Allah, I
noticed that when you heard it was him,
you said,
but then when he came in, you smiled in
his face and you placated him and you
didn't say any of that to his face and
then when he left."
And so the prophet sallallah.aii Wasam
said,
"When have you known me to be a vulgar
man?" Meaning someone who would insult
someone to his face. That's vulgar.
That's univilized. That's primitive.
When have you known me to be that
person? He said,
[Silence]
This is he says the worst of people
are a type of person that people avoid
him just to avoid his evil because any
way that you try to seriously more than
superficially interact with them,
they'll bite you. That's the kind of
person they are. No one escapes their
evil. So the worst of people are those
whom people avoid in order to be safe
from their evil. Everyone deals with
them. How? Superficially. They have no
good deep friends. They have no deep
family. They have no deep brotherhood
because anyone who comes in any way
close they get bit. So people just want
to avoid him. This is the worst kind of
people. And so the prophet here
when the man came in he didn't say
right
when the man said
it was
and he said
what a what a bad man.
If the man would have come in and then
when he came in he said you're the best
of men that would have been mud.
That is hypocrisy. That's different. But
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
didn't change the truth for him. What
did he instead do? He merely refrained
from telling him the whole story or what
he truly thought. He dealt with him at a
superficial level and didn't deal with
him in the way that he would deal with
others. This is
and this is one of the greatest levels
of etiquette and character
that the prophets and messengers are
given the wisdom to be able to perfect.
So we see kind of now the difference
here between compromise and diplomacy.
We will end this all with this statement
of Allah
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
Huh?
I can't hear because more than one
person is speaking at the same time. Say
it again.
Allah says the believer will never side
with the disbeliever
against
the believer another believer unless and
it's not here unless
but what the believer will do is refrain
because of the sake of harm. This is
what we call mud.
So the scholars give us a difference.
The difference here is a person who
becomes Muslim in Mecca and is unable to
proclaim his Islam. So he doesn't say
I've publicly I've become Muslim. He's
Muslim, but he's unable to proclaim it
because he will be harmed. So, he keeps
it to himself.
The difference between that and a person
who
says the opposite, they're Muslim, but
then they worship other than Allah in
public in order to plate the enemies.
We understand the difference. So there's
a difference between not saying the
whole truth and because of a necessity
and saying falsehood to plate
that is
I know our talk was a little bit
longer this evening but anyways we'll be
done with this in the next couple days
starting tomorrow night Tuesday night
we will be discussing the rulings of
fasting inshallah tomorrow night after
isa and Tuesday after if you have any
questions you can ask me then inshallah
yes sir
I fear for your safety I've already gone
over time
uhhuh
not during the time of the
Malik Marwan, he walked